Some people are so full of life and and energy,...
...but for some reason, even when you seem to get more than enough sleep,...
...you're still fighting off yawns and fatigue through the day.
If you know the number of hours of sleep isn't the problem,...
...the second most common cause of fatigue...
...comes from lack of physical activity and a poor diet.
Study after study finds that adults who began light exercise a few times a week...
...reported more energy after six weeks.
People who exercise more regularly also report sleeping better...
...even though studies show that they aren't sleeping any longer.
While many studies show coffee is good for your health,...
...research shows that your reliance on it can make you more sleepy.
Caffeine blocks adenosine in your brain, which normally accumulates through the day...
...and makes you sleepy at night,...
...but consuming coffee or energy drinks less than six hours before bed...
...can ultimately affect your sleep quality.
As a result, people who don't use caffeine...
...often report feeling less tired in the morning.
Your mental well-being plays a role, too.
Anxiety is a big one.
Worrying what people think, always feeling tense about work...
...or being overly concerned about every decision can be physically exhausting...
...and fatigue is one of the main symptoms of generalized anxiety disorder.
Not only that, but anxiety may be affecting your sleep quality.
On another serious end, depression can cause both physical and emotional fatigue,...
...which more sleep won't necessarily relieve.